what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to lil
dirk should abduct
featuring poo sheisty a lot of my
videos featuring like with music get
demonetized like
pretty much every single one so if you
guys want to support me
in pushing these videos out and just
support the channel hit that subscribe
button
give me a comment and a like just
because i like doing these but honestly
like it's tough because they get
demonetized like every single time
um okay i should have ducked
this will be fun these are captions
any time i can't run on the game
[Music]
i forgot sometimes i put these on put
stuff on fast
when i watch it i have to turn it off
okay
[Music]
he said i can't be around no gang
members
now i i don't want to make assumptions
here
but it looks like just based on the
scene in the music video that he
is in fact around gang members
cherry production let's get it throw
that mass on when you jump out first you
better blast
yeah we don't like slow [ __ ] don't hit
them switches fast
game ain't gonna light a city highway
strikers they don't last
when you pop in with your kills you
better check your gas
let's get it throw that mask on when you
jump out first you better blast
yeah if you don't like slow [ __ ] don't
hit some switches fast
game ain't gonna lie to city highway
strikers they don't last
when you pop in with your killers you
better check your game
i think basically he's saying that he's
coming in with some guys that'll shoot
you
i heard like strikers killers i think
it's the same theme like
it's it's he's just talking threats what
we don't party on other blocks they [ __ ]
with other odds let's get it
they come around like you gain that got
your brother you say his name inside a
song that got your brother hot a skit
then leave them hanging without a lawyer
that [ __ ] dumb as [ __ ]
you come out sour at your gun little boy
you dumb as [ __ ]
ain't no quick run to the store they pop
out fire you up
[Music]
okay so he's seeing a crep which is a
gang
okay if he goes to the store he's gonna
get
shot up not something they want so they
don't really go to the store
i told my p.o through the gate that i
get [ __ ] high she asked me how
[Music]
okay he said poppy what is a poppy and
then glocky is that like a gun
he also talked about doing some weed
and other drugs to make him hot i think
he's talking about weed but
it could be a variety of things you know
all them [ __ ] wanna [ __ ] me i don't
give them money
one [ __ ] thought i told her yeah i said
you better block me
he survived went to the head but it
[ __ ] up his body
you think he offered a red the way that
[ __ ] nodded
he don't even know about drugs he
sailing oxycontin
you trying to judge
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i can't understand like half of
that but he did talk about how
girls want to get with him because he
has money let me
[Music]
they make me mad enough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay from what i understand he's just
summarizing that
he is a gangster he's super hard
and he's not afraid of anything you
[ __ ] goose ain't got no gun you went
away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
did he kill someone over hundred dollar
bills
i don't even slam them out just be
yourself stay 300 get money monday
through
to pray to try they every sunday tied up
in
[Music]
he's saying that he's never gonna run
from a fight
he's gonna go out like
[Music]
[Music]
before i spin
[Music]
okay uh i really did not like that song
i'm gonna give it like a five out of ten
it was okay
i don't like it when they like mumble
like i can't understand what you're
saying
but the gist of the song is i'm cool
i do fights and stuff
i also do drugs and i get money let me
know what other themes in the song
that i missed and comment below what
song i should do next
and comment if you prefer these
reactions or if you prefer
like the kevin samuels type manosphere
type reactions anyways talk to you guys
next time